This guy's probably, like I said, he's
probably just one step lower in the
sewage than Orthodox duck lips. He
quotes or references a 9th century
historian, Christian Hunain Ibanak.
Remember, 9th century 800. And when I
research, he had translated the Greek
Old Testament into Aramaic, Arabic, I'm
sorry. And he says he took the word doxy
hem as hemmed. He also has indulus.
Watch the argument here.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. He has also
indoxis.
>> Indoxus. Endocus.
>> Indoxus as Mahammad.
>> Indoxis as Mahhammad. Uh, would it be
fair to say Ahmed would mean the person
who has the most stocks according to
him?
>> You understand that question, Mike?
>> Um, I'm I need to know what those words
actually refer to.
>> All right. So, can I can I explain it to
him? I can explain it to him if he
wants.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Explain to him real quick.
>> All right. So, he says, "According to
the source, 9th century historian
Christian Hunain Ibn Hak." So, Hainb
have a Greek Arabic lexicon. I think
that's what he's referring to. He has
the Greek word do or do as hemmed
is the root that means praise. Now,
so they look at what a 9th century
Assyrian Christian did by translating
the Greek Old Testament into Arabic and
saw that he took the word for glory,
rendered it as hemp, meaning praise
and endoc.
And then they make the leap that's
Muhammad.
And wouldn't that show that Jesus
mentioned Ahmed?
Listen, watch. Which is the root word
for Ahmed and Muhammad.
>> Right. Um, and he also uses indoxos for
Muhammad. Okay. So, he's saying um, can
you finish the repeat that last
sentence? It doesn't show here. I'm on
the YouTube.
>> What does he say after? says he says um
would it be fair to say Ahmed would mean
the person who has the most do according
to him? So right so he's saying does
Ahmed therefore mean the one who has the
most doos
you understand what they just did
9th century Assyrian
Hainb
translates the Greek Old Testament into
Arabic. He uses the word
hemp. Hemp like ham amida.
The root from which you get ahmed,
Muhammad, Mahmud,
praise. He uses that Arabic term to
translate the Greek word doxy
dois
and that's old testament.
And then Dina no response then makes the
leap. Wouldn't it then be fair that
Ahmed is a person who's most glorious?
So he will take the term glory when it
appears in the Old Testament render it
in Arabic as Mahm Muhammad right Hamida.
And that means somehow
that the Quran is right that Jesus
mentioned a messenger whose name would
be Ahmed.
Okay.
>> No idea because again this is completely
irrelevant to the topic. So I what was
the topic? Is Muhammad in the Bible?
And
how do you prove that Muhammad is in the
Bible? by going to a translation of the
Greek Old Testament into Arabic to see
how doxy doas
and its derivatives
in do means in glory right one with
glory in because that preposition can
mean in or with and the Assyrian
translates it with the forms of hamida
or ham praise from which you get
Muhammad Ahmed Mahm
like when you say alhamdulillah alhamd
and then jump to
Ahmed
being a person who's most glorious
without first proving
that
Jesus mentioned a prophet who would have
a form of the name that would correspond
to the Arabic Ahmed.
This is how they prove their case.
>> Not prepared for this issue.
>> Completely irrelevant to the topic. Has
nothing to do with Muhammad in the
Bible. What Christian was saying
>> has everything to do. Can I respond now?
It has everything to do with Muhammad in
the Bible. because I preeded the debate
and said that according to the earliest
view according to scholars like EP
Sanders, Rudolph Baltman, Adala Collins,
Bartman and most of German scholarship,
the son of man was a distinct figure
that Jesus spoke about who comes at the
right hand of the father. Notice right
hand of the father. I'm going to use
them now in a minute to bury him. Son of
man, look. Look, he's opening up his
mouth for the black stone and for
[clears throat]
the buffet. That mouth is when it opens
when Dena comes and licks his tongue
like Muhammad licked this the tongue of
his grandsons and when he wants to lick
the black stone and smooch the black
stone and when he stuffs his face in the
buffet line. We're going to get to the
meat, guys. Just let me get through
this. We're going to get into the meat.
>> And he is the most glorified. He is
Ahmed. So thank you for admitting that
according to the [clears throat]
scholarship Jesus spoke of Ahmed to
come.
>> Did you you see the leak?
>> So the response
>> did you not did you notice he appeals to
EP Sanders Mark and others that when
Jesus spoke of the son of man he was
speaking of someone other than him and
that son of man is glorious and
therefore that mean Jesus spoke of Ahmed
when he said the son of man who will
come in glory.
You see that right
now? Are you ready for the shish kebab?
Okay guys, remember the time stamp.
2 hours 25 minutes 40 seconds. So watch
the logic.
Watch the logic.
Scholars like Bartman, AP Sanders, Bruce
Chilton said that when Jesus spoke of
the apocalyptic son of son of man, he
was referring to someone other than him.
And since that son of man will be
glorious. That mean Jesus mentioned
Ahmed because Ahmed means the one who is
most praised.
Yes. No. You got it.
Okay. Now let's go to the passages and
see. Let's go through the son of man
sayings.
Let's assume Jesus is referring to
someone other than him. Just for
assumption sake. You ready? Now begins
the ex Jesus. Oh, we're gonna have fun.
Just let me vent at this disgusting fat
pig who doesn't want to do a real debate
with me. But hi, like Aisha did with her
dolls. So the son of man, the
apocalyptic son of man, he's saying
apocalyptic son of man. That's
Muhammad. Because according to these
scholars, when Jesus spoke of the son of
man who would come at the end of the
age, that's not him. That's someone
else. Okay? That's what they say. All
right, I I'll I'll I'll go with that. I
got you. I got you, SHOW. I GOT HIM,
JOE. I got him.
I got him. Show.
I got him.
All right. According to Snowlicker,
Licky Licky, when Jesus spoke of the son
of man, he's not speaking of himself.
He's speaking of someone else. And why
do they want to connect this with
Muhammad? Watch how the geniuses.
Watch the geniuses.
And then they will see the son of man
coming [laughter]
in clouds with great power and glory.
Now watch the Einsteines
due to a 9th century translation
a
translation of the Greek Old Testament
into Arabic by an Assyrian Christian
800s right suppose after Muhammad he
rendered the word doxy
with the form of the verb where we get
Muhammad Ahmed Hamida.
So now watch it. Because Jesus said
because Jesus said because Jesus said
the son of man will come in glory. And a
9th century translation
a 9th century translation.
Okay. Translated the Greek word with the
form of the Arabic verb verb hamida.
where Hammed Ham Hamid where you get
Muhammad Ahmed that means the son of man
is Ahmed because glory in Arabic can be
rendered with the Arabic root where you
get Ahmed and Muhammad. So that's how
you know the son of man is Muhammad
and that's where Jesus predicted the
coming of Ahmed.
You see the logic?
You see the logic, right? Okay. Well,
I'm gonna go with it.
Okay, I'm I still want to laugh.
So, a 9th century Arabic translation
proves that glory here means the son of
man is glorious and therefore that's
Ahmed.
And the Muslims still endorse these
guys.
Okay, now let's let's go. We're going to
have fun, guys. Let's go. Yeah, I swear
I want to laugh again. [laughter]
Okay, but let's see who the son of man
is. Did you remember what the fat pig
said? He said, "Son of man sits at the
right hand of the father."
Remember he said it, right? The fat pig.
But he kept silent and did not answer
again. The high priest was I'm sorry. He
kept silent. Did not answer again. The
high priest was questioning him and said
to him, "Are you the Christ, the son of
the blessed one?" Jesus said, "I am."
You shall see the son of man sitting at
the right hand of the power coming with
the clouds of heaven. Now remember he
said the son of man sits at the right
hand of the father. Remember that. All
right. He just said Muhammad is the son
of Allah and Allah is his father.
Matthew 16:27 28. For the son of man is
coming going to come in the glory.
There's that word ahmed.
So now if we follow if we take it
literally for the son of man is going to
come in
ahmed.
He's going to come in the Ahmed. So what
DOES THAT MEAN? BUT I'M GENEROUS.
Son of man will come in the glory of his
father. So that means the son of man
will come in the donkey of the father
in the glory. Right? Remember glory is
supposed to be Muhammad Ahmed.
So this is the glory of his father. So
does he come in the glory? Meaning he
comes with glory. Okay, but I like it
better to say here when the son of man
comes in the Ahmed of his father. Jokes
aside, let's go with it. We'll translate
the preposition. For the son of man is
going to come with the glory of his
father. And that means he's glorious.
And therefore he's Ahmed because you can
translate the word glory into Arabic
Ahmed Muhammad Mahm.
All right? Because some 9th century
Assyrian Christian rendered doxy as
Hamid or Hamida Hammed. All right. But
wait guys, we have a problem.
We have a problem.
He just told you Muhammad is a son of
Allah and Allah is his father.
And he just told you Muhammad will come
on the day of judgment to sit on the
throne and judge and reward people. He
just made Muhammad
Malikaden,
the king. Malik, the Lord, the master of
the day of judgment.
He just had Muhammad doing what the
Quran says Allah will do. And on top of
that, he has Allah being Muhammad's
father.
See what he just did.
Truly I say to you, there are some of
those who are standing here will not
taste death until they see the son of
man coming in his kingdom. So according
to him, Muhammad showed up in the
lifetime of the apostles.
So Muhammad was there.
All right?
So now note what he said. Allah is
Muhammad's father.
Muhammad is the master of the day of
judgment. Right? The king of the day of
judgment. Muhammad will come with his
angels. So he owns the angels and he
will judge mankind
and Muhammad will appear in his kingdom
because son of man will appear in his
kingdom during the lifetime of the
apostles of Jesus.
This is what these guys thought was a
victory.